all right the rtx 3090 from nvidia this
is the thickest and the quickest gpu
this is the king of the geforce gpus
right now it is big and it's super
expensive comes in at 1500
but just for comparison the 2080 ti this
is a much smaller card the 20 ti is like
i don't know it feels like a toy in
comparison to this thing like look how
big this thing is now
this chunky boy i'm going to jump into
the benchmarks first it's probably the
least important part of the conversation
there's way more important stuff to talk
about but for the people that are
interested 4k gaming is probably like 8
to 10 better than an rtx 3080 in most
games it's nothing crazy occasionally
might hit like 11 12 better but for the
average person that's looking for a new
gpu it doesn't seem to make sense right
10 12 better at best for more than
double the price
what's going on so here's the thing this
is not a 4k gaming card if that's what
you're looking for rtx 3080 has you
covered what this thing does what this
thing has is a ton
of video memory it's got a huge 24
gigabyte stash of it and for some
creative workflows that can make use of
extra ram it pushes out like 20 to 25
improvements over the 3080 so in blender
and with octane autodesk arnold v-ray
basically anything that can take
advantage of a lot of video memory the
3090 delivers some really nice gains a
20 to maybe 25 improvement in workflow
speed can be very significant if that's
your profession if that's how you earn
your living paying the extra 800 bucks
to pick up a 3090 instead of a 3080 is
probably uh i mean for a lot of those
people a good choice
now for some people like myself included
the 3090 does not affect workflow very
much over 3080 so i shoot in 5k and
occasionally 6k for my videos and the
difference in adobe premiere is
negligible like i feel like the 3080
does an amazing job the 3090 does a
slightly better job it's not really
worth it to me to pay the extra 800
bucks for a 30 90 if video editing was
all i was doing now i want to talk about
8k gaming because this card has been
touted by nvidia as being capable of
playing 8k games at 60 frames per second
and yes it can be done with dlss and the
huge amounts of video memory this thing
has it can push out pretty smooth frame
rates in 8k and for the past few days
that's what i've been doing on dell
monitor 8k it's been an experience so
this is what i've noticed about it 8k
gaming is highly dependent on the type
of game that you're playing so stuff
like doom and overwatch or games where
the action is so quick it's kind of hard
to appreciate the increase in resolution
like the extra details are there there's
definitely more pixels and if you look
for it like if you're looking at your
gun you look at the kind of features and
details on the artwork it's there you
stick your face right up to the screen
you'll notice it but the thing is when
you're playing these games you tend not
to look at the stuff that much you tend
to focus on your targeting reticle and
the actual gameplay right the other
stuff like the explosions the flares the
weapon effects particle effects it's all
in higher resolution now in 8k but your
eye just isn't naturally drawn to that
stuff normally like you have to go out
of your way to notice it but for other
games like red dead redemption and
horizon zero dawn these are games where
the extra detail is nice and i found
that i just noticed this stuff naturally
it's not like a mind-blowing experience
right the detail is there and it's
actually really nice but it doesn't
change the feel of the game to me i
don't feel like when i play these games
in high resolution that the experience
is all that different from when i played
it at 4k or even 1080p from being
completely honest to me higher
resolutions are nice but it's never been
something i've chased after i've always
gone after higher frame rate gaming but
now with the rtx 3090 you get all of it
you get high frame rates you get crazy
good image quality with rtx dlss and if
you want you can go for ultra high
resolutions 8k gaming is actually a
thing on this machine the thing is it is
super expensive not just the card right
the panels to see in 8k my screen is
like four and a half five thousand
dollars the tvs that you've seen on
youtube those are like thirty thousand
dollar units they're extremely expensive
so the cost of this card like the
fifteen hundred dollar add-on to be able
to to play in 8k is only a portion of
the cost it's a nice experience but it's
a very expensive one right now so the
cart itself it's thick af but it's also
very heavy so this is coming in at
almost 2.2 kilos and i was worried about
sag but the weight is distributed pretty
nicely because the pcie bracket has
three holes that line up with the three
slots so it's a nice distribution of
weight across the different slots the
fans so just like the 3080 it's got two
fans one that has air that flows through
it and one that expels air out the back
these fans i really like them they're
quiet even on load provided your system
is properly cooled but the fans because
they're bigger than the 3080 their top
speed isn't nearly as annoying of a wine
so these hit i think 2 600 rpm at full
speed and the 3080 hits 3 700 rpm it's a
very notable difference in sound
the temperatures on the fenders edition
are okay i do think that you need a
relatively large case to make this thing
cool properly like if you have a small
case even if it fits you're just pumping
a ton of heat into the system because of
the nature of this fan configuration and
because this is a big heat sink with big
fans there's a lot of heat coming in you
got to find a way to exhaust it if you
have a big case with good airflow this
is great
now the 1500 question that the most
important question is whether or not you
should purchase this whether or not this
is worth the extra 800
over rtx 3080 and i think that question
has become way more complex than it
really needs to be if you can make use
of the vram like the 24 gigs of memory
on this card i think this is a very
reasonably priced gpu it's not a quadro
it's not a titan but it's a 1 500 card
right not a 3 000 card you don't get the
certified pro drivers you also don't get
uh ngx you also get like crippled
tensor performance if that's the stuff
you're going for but again fifteen
hundred dollars not three thousand
dollars now if you're a gamer that has a
ton of money you wanna try you're
handing 8k gaming
sure you already bought this
congratulations but for the regular
people that are into 4k gaming or less
1400 widescreen 1080p widescreen
this is so
extra it really is super unnecessary
because it's not just the cost of the
card you need to have a 850 watt power
supply or probably like
750 if you're being
chintzy you do need a relatively large
case to fit in so you may need to
upgrade a whole bunch of stuff till to
make this fit so i think for regular
gamers
the 3080 is the way to go the thing is
that card is so good that card is
amazing and that's why this is a more
complex
conversation right this thing looks
expensive and it feels weirdly
overpriced because the 3080 is as good
as it as it is but
that that's the reality right that card
is meant for gaming this card is meant
for rich people with 8k tvs
and workflows that can make use of video
memory okay hope you guys enjoyed this
video thumbs if you liked it subs if you
loved it i'll see you guys next time
[Music]